[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le 7-8 choisir le
deuxième numéro de la saison toutes vos
idées sorties dans le département et
tout de suite on commence avec le
sommaire les journées du patrimoine se
déroule tout le week end l'occasion de
redécouvrir la richesse culturelle des
yvelines à magny les hameaux le domaine
de broue ci ouvre ses portes pour une
visite son jardin classé monument
historique
les journées du patrimoine c'est aussi
et surtout pour les plus jeunes à
elancourt jeu de piste à la commanderie
des templiers ou happy manif au 7 mars
mélanie pocket nous présentera sa
sélection la saison des amours a
commencé chez les cernes et mal ce défi
pour impressionner les femelles et c'est
la meilleure période pour écouter son
cri de caractéristiques le brame
des animations sont proposées à l'espace
rambouillet et c'est justement ambroise
graf en a qui est avec nous il a quitté
sa forêt pour nous parler des visites
menées jusqu'au 14 octobre bonjour
ambrose graff un bon jour et mélanie
poquet nous a rejoint également avec
toutes ces super idée sortie pour
occuper les plus jeunes bonjour mélanie
ou gens qui me mais avant de passer aux
entretiens on va d'abord parler du
domaine de broue si justement mélanie
vous avez découvert son jardin 300 ans
d'histoire au coeur de magny les hameaux
a visité lors des journées du patrimoine
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images etc on a de la nette qui monte en
fleurs on a de la roquette à our nova en
italien il ya des navets derrière à
l'abri des regards à magny les hameaux
une histoire qui dure celle du domaine
de brou essayer de son jardin construit
en 1711 est classé monument historique
le plan du jardin c'est à dire cette
grande allée est une des deux croisés et
d'origine
on le voit sur les premiers plans ce qui
est assez remarquable
ce qui a changé ce sont des arbres en
espalier qui sont eux qui sont devenus à
la mode plutôt au début du 19e siècle
car les arbres étaient en gobelets avant
imaginée par pierre cailleteau de
l'assurance le jardin suit les préceptes
de jean baptiste de la quintinie
architecte de louis xiv le jardin aux
portes l'aller l'aller parfaitement
droit de visible de la maison
l'alimentation en eau dans le coin en
haut pour qu'on puisse l'on puisse
descendre la fermeture de murs pour
protéger et surtout une exposition une
protection des vents dominants de
l'ouest puisque même dans les pires
tempêtes qu'on a pu connu de jardin ne
bouge pas un jardin et un domaine aux
habitants illustre les vice comme paul
ancien maire de magny les hameaux de
1935 et 1940 où l'une de ses filles une
certaine louise weiss journaliste
écrivain et européennes et les journées
du patrimoine ça se fait avant tout en
famille à saint quentin en yvelines
certaines activités ont été pensés
spécialement pour les enfants mélanie
vous en avez noté on va pouvoir
découvrir l histoire grâce à des énigmes
et que ce que propose la commanderie des
templiers de la villedieu
le site a été fondée à la fin du 12e
siècle par un groupe de chevaliers et
c'est même chevalier avait pour mission
de protéger les chrétiens parti en
croisade
alors lors de ces énigmes il y en a pour
tous les âges même pour les plus jeunes
puisque le premier jeu pisté pour les
enfants de 4 ans écoutez donc ya pas
besoin de savoir lire c'est faire partir
de de pictogrammes et à partir de photos
et puis il y aura même parcours un autre
parcours pour les enfants à partir de 8
ans où là il y aura des ennemis mais des
codes et des codes secrets cd découvrir
en fait l'origine des templiers ce qui
s'est passé sur skis et ses pattes et
sur l'étude et en même temps il y aura
des épreuves
il y aura des épreuves techniques pour
les plus jeunes mais aussi pour les
adolescents parce qu'il ya des jeux de
rôle ils seront invités à plonger dans
la vie d'une commanderie au xiiie siècle
et toutes ces animations ont lieu le
week-end des 10 heures à 18 heures ces
journées du patrimoine c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir des lieux de
manière originale notamment au quartier
de 7 mars à va dans cet aveu même
manifesté de manière un joyeux et décalé
la happy manif vous attend à 14 heures à
16 heures devant le prisme à elancourt à
l'origine à david rolland un chorégraphe
français casque sur la tête comme vous
voyez sur les images allez vous balader
découvrir l'histoire de ce quartier qui
date des années 70 la voie du
chorégraphe va vous donner des
indications à suivre on découvre très
vite qu'il ya deux groupes différents
qui entendent des choses différentes
parce qu'il permet déjà que les groupes
se croisent ne fasse pas les mêmes
actions que les actions des groupes se
complètent et voilà ça crée un dialogue
en soit entre deux personnes soit entre
deux groupes
et ça rajoute un peu à cette atmosphère
que j'aime joyeuse en fait j'ai récupéré
des interviews d'aider des architectes
sur md lendemain la dame des landes de
l'artiste de la main divine qui est la
main qui est derrière le prisme alors
pour participer à cette déambulation
chorégraphique joyeuse et décalé
n'oubliez pas de vous inscrire cette api
manif s'adresse à tout le monde dès
l'âge de 8 ans alors jeu de piste ou
manifestation joyeuse et encore plus de
choix à retrouver sur internet tout le
programme des journées du patrimoine est
disponible sur le site kiosque point ski
point fr merci mélanie nous avoir
présenté ses activités
on part maintenant en forêt de
rambouillet avec notre invité
[Musique]
la fin de l'été marque le début des
hostilités chez lés cerfs les mâles se
disputent les femelles et c'est donc à
cette période que l'on peut entendre
leurs cris le brame du cerf un cri
rauque et profond qui résonne dans les
bois l'espace rambouillet vous propose
de partir à la rencontre de cet animal
majestueux en brosse graffin le
directeur va nous donner plus de détails
des visites sont organisées du 15
septembre au 14 octobre
effectivement nous organisons des
visites comme tous les ans entre la mi
septembre et la mi octobre
c'est l'occasion sur une durée grosso
modo deux heures soit au crépuscule ou
au lever du jour d'aller observer de
plus près et avec une certitude à
l'espace rambouillet cette manifestation
particulière et donc sa visite à sont
accompagnés justement d'un guide
alors quel est l'intérêt d'avoir un
accompagnateur et connaît mieux les
animaux le terrain alors déjà
l'accompagnateur va pouvoir guider les
les visiteurs pour bien trouver les
animaux ce qui est pas évident on est
sur un an un espace de 200 hectares qui
est clos mais les animaux quand même une
grosse latitude pour se déplacer donc le
guide valu ne pas aller au bon endroit
et puis aussi fournir des explications
en fait sur le comportement aussi des
animaux c'est vraiment une scénographie
la nature particulière et le guide peut
donner un petit peu des clés interne
atteint d'interprétation alors justement
quelques clés d'interprétation de ces de
ces animaux je l'expliqué
qu'est ce que c'est que le brame du cerf
qu'est ce que ça signifie secret
le brame du cerf en fait c'est un cri
très fort rock c'est à la base de
l'intimidation
en fait c'est lié à ce combat entre
entre les entre les mâles pour aller
féconder la femelle l'arbre de biche et
donc première étape s'est montré un peu
sa virilité sa force auprès des
congénères et avec ce cri derrière assez
âpre il ya souvent un défi physique des
combats et ça peut aller jusqu'à la mort
d'un des deux combattants quoi forcément
jusqu'à la mort c'est parce qu'on
souhaite à chaque fois avoir tout le jeu
de rôle entre les mâles ou les jeunes en
fait regarder un petit peu essayé de
participer mais dès qu un mâle adulte
approche non ils vont décamper et tout
ce petit jeu d'intimidation en fait
quand vous avez un spécialiste ça permet
de le décoder quoi donc vous l'avez dit
justement c'est le crépuscule et le soir
donc ces 2,6 c 6 heures 30 on 18h30 pour
ceux qui souhaiteraient voilà exactement
et sachant qu'on a plus de soirée on a
quelques matinées con con mais surtout
les week-ends d'accord très bien on va
passer du coup parce que à un autre un
autre animal parce que l'espace
rambouillet il n'y a pas que les
cervidés il ya aussi les rapaces et
jusqu'au 5 novembre on peut encore
profiter des spectacles avec quelques
nouveautés notamment
on a toujours effectivement jusqu'à
début novembre trois spectacles par jour
aux démonstrations de vols de rapaces et
pour cette année on a plusieurs
nouveautés notamment donc un couple de
condor qu'elle est l'espèce un peu
problématique en termes de taille des
rapaces pour l'accueil depuis cette
année dont qui volent devant les les
visiteurs et puis aussi de dispositifs
ne l'a plus sur les comportements où on
arrive maintenant à faire
venir sur l'air de représentation
manière totalement
libre des chouettes effraies qui sortent
de la forêt je n'en dis pas plus il faut
laisser un petit peu de mystère et puis
aussi un traîneau en fait avec une peau
de lièvre dessus on actionne et ça
permet de faire venir un aigle et c'est
de toujours de simuler un comportement
naturel
alors justement delà de l'aspect
divertissement l'espace rambouillet
ouvre aussi pour la protection des
oiseaux et ce type de spectacle ça
permet aussi peut-être de mieux
comprendre leur comportement
oui c'est le parti pris on fait du
spectacle on reste vraiment sur les
comportements d'un haut niveau visuel et
le commentaire reste pédagogique c'est
notre parti pris et au delà de du
spectacle on est aussi inséré dans des
programmes de conservation la plus
concret sur le territoire est
essentiellement faite avec le pygargue
de stellaire qui est donc un aigle
pêcheur russe en voie d'extinction et
donc avec le zoo de moscou en fait on
sait si à l'espace rambouillet en fait
qui a vu la première il ya eu les
premières naissances de pygargues à
matane d'année donc maintenant on a pu
et se met sur différents parcs et puis
on attend en fait le ok du programme de
conservation pour la réintroduction dans
leurs milieux d'origine en russie
sachant qu'aujourd'hui
tant que le milieu il reste polluer les
causes restent là ça sert à rien d'aller
réintroduire s'ils vont être exterminés
juste après donc vraiment pour leur
préservation en tout cas merci beaucoup
ambroise graffin pour toutes ces
précisions
donc on le rappelle pour aller à la
rencontre du roi de la forêt c'est dès
ce vendredi 15 septembre le matin à 6h30
et le soir à 18h30
tous les détails se trouvent sur le site
internet de l'espace rambouillet merci
beaucoup en brosse graffin merci à vous
et on passe maintenant à notre agenda
avec deux derniers rendez vous à noter
[Musique]
on prend la direction de montigny le
bretonneux avec deux événements
d'importance ce week end samedi le
centre sportif coubertin se transforme
en salle d'arcade montini games day
toute nouvelle manifestation dédiée aux
jeux vidéo vous attend
tout l'après midi retro gaming jeux sur
tablette ou tournoi fifa avec un lot à
gagner
il y en aura pour tous les goûts et pour
tous les âges c'est en tout cas ce que
nous a promis eric stener le responsable
jeunesse de la ville
on va retrouver les fameux mario kart
etc
on va toutes les générations de nintendo
j'ai eu beaucoup ont connu les jeux de
barbe a fait un grand classique ou là
des baby foots externe machin on va
retrouver bien sûr les pac man effet
grand jeu d'arcade qui ont parlé à
beaucoup de générations
donc voilà on a voulu quelque chose de
très émotif très large et les festivités
se poursuivent dimanche avec pleins
phares sur l'auto partait pour un voyage
en italie c'est la thématique de cette
troisième édition
les curieux et les passionnés de
véhicules anciens ont rendez vous ce
dimanche à la ferme du manet marie
toussaint nous donne le programme des
peintures italiennes des collectionneurs
des petites voitures italiennes
voilà le thème sort italie donc
plusieurs stands à l'intérieur même de
la grange des expositions de voitures
prestigieuses à l'intérieur de la grange
des vieilles voitures qui seront
présentes avec nous sur le circuit le
matin donc une trentaine de véhicules
pour circuler sur les huit quartiers de
la ville de montigny
si tu te loisirs est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivis et mission
retrouver sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro 10 il a
profité de votre week-end et des
différentes sorties proposées sur le
territoire
ouais